IN "SEEN AND UNSEEN."
FIRST THE HAT THAT DARE NOT SHOW
ITS BRIM.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
>> THERE IS SO MUCH NEWS TO
COVER EVERY DAY IN TRUMP WORLD
THAT YOU WOULD THINK THE PRESS
WOULD STICK TO REAL REPORTING
AND ANALYSIS ON IMPORTANT
POLITICAL DEVELOPMENT, BUT NO.
MOVE OVER, AND I WENT TO WORK.
NOW THE BUSINESS OF DISSING
FASHION ACCESSORIES.
NO, NO, NO, NOT THAT ONE.
NO, NO, NOT UGLY FLIP-FLOPS.
YES, THAT ONE.
BINGO.
>> THE HAT CARRIES A CERTAIN
CONNOTATION THAT PROVOKES A
CONDITIONED REACTION FROM MANY
PEOPLE.
ESPECIALLY FOR MARGINALIZED
>> AMERICA IS ALREADY THE MOST
PUNITIVE DEVELOPED NATION ON
EARTH.
FOR POOR PEOPLE, PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
WE THROW MILLIONS OF LIVES ONTO
THE BONFIRE EVERY YEAR.
THEY JUST DON'T NORMALLY LOOK
LIKE THE TEENAGERS IN MAGA HATS.
SPEAK OF THIS MAKE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN HAT IS AS MADDENING AND
FRUSTRATING AND TRIGGERING FOR
ME TO LOOK AT AS A KKK HOOD.
>> Laura: WELL, THEY TRIGGER
ME IN THE WAKE OF THE COVINGTON
HIGH SCHOOL FRACAS, THE RED MAGA
HAS BECOME A TALISMAN OF EVIL AD
HAS BECOME A TALISMAN OF EVIL AS
HAS BECOME A TALISMAN OF EVIL AM
HAS BECOME A TALISMAN OF EVIL AF
HAS BECOME A TALISMAN OF EVIL AW
HAS BECOME A TALISMAN OF EVIL AI
HAS BECOME A TALISMAN OF EVIL AS
HAS BECOME A TALISMAN OF EVIL AR
HAS BECOME A TALISMAN OF EVIL AM
HAS BECOME A TALISMAN OF EVIL AE
HAS BECOME A TALISMAN OF EVIL AY
HAS BECOME A TALISMAN OF EVIL A.
SAVANNAH GUTHRIE BROUGHT IT UP
WITH THE STUDENT AT THE CENTER
OF THE CONTROVERSY, NICK
SANDMANN TODAY ON
"THE TODAY SHOW."
>> DO YOU THINK IF YOU WEREN'T
WEARING THAT HAT, THIS MIGHT NOT
HAVE HAPPENED OR HE MIGHT HAVE
BEEN DIFFERENT?
>> THAT'S POSSIBLE, BUT I WOULD
HAVE TO ASSUME WHAT MR. PHILLIPS
WAS THINKING, AND I WOULD RATHER
LET HIM SPEAK FOR WHY HE CAME UP
TO US.
>> Laura: SO THE RED HAT NOW
IS APPARENTLY THE ANNABELLE OF
HEAD COVERINGS, I THINK CAPABLE
OF UNLEASHING EVIL WHEREVER
IT IS SEEN.
THERE'S ALSO A SUBTEXT HERE
MEANT TO INTIMIDATE.
WE ARE GOING TO GET INTO THAT.
THE LEFT WANTS TO TAKE AWAY YOU
ARE RIGHT TO WEAR WHATEVER THE
HECK YOU WANT.
NOW, THIS IS -- IT'S WEIRD.
IT'S A LEFT-WING VERSION OF
PURITANISM, THEIR OWN VERSION OF
IT.
WHERE THEY GET TO DICTATE WHAT
GOODY FILL-IN THE BLANK IS
ALLOWED TO WEAR AND ANYONE WHO
DARES TO VIOLATE THEIR DICTATES
IS EITHER ASHAMED OR JUST
LABELED HATEFUL, XENOPHOBIC,
MISOGYNISTIC, UNREASONABLE,
STUPID, AND OF COURSE RACIST.
BISHOP TALBERT SWAN, HARVARD
DIVINITY SCHOOL GRAD, TWEETED
"WHEN TRAYVON MARTIN WAS
MURDERED, YOU ALSO BLACK PARENT
SHOULD LET THEIR BOYS WEAR
HOODIES.
IF THEY DIDN'T WANT THEM
PERCEIVED AS THUGS.
THEY ALL DON'T WANT YOUR BOYS
PERCEIVED AS RACIST LITTLE
JACKASSES FOR WEARING MAGA
HATS."
MR. SWAN WILL JOIN US IN A
MOMENT.
THIS LEFTIST NARRATIVE THAT A
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN HAT IS
AKIN TO WEARING SOME NAZI
UNIFORM, IT'S PATENTLY
RIDICULOUS AND IT'S OFFENSIVE.
IT'S JUST PLAIN STUPID.
BUT THIS IS THE DEFORMATION AND
INTIMIDATION THAT THEY LEFT
HAPPILY PERPETUATES.
BY THE WAY, WITH LITTLE TO NO
PUSHBACK.
PREDICTABLY OF COURSE NEVER
TRUMP REPUBLICANS ARE ALSO
TAKING UP THE CHORUS, FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" TWEETING
"DON'T LET YOUR CATHOLIC SCHOOLS
STUDENTS WHERE MAGA HATS FOR A
FIELD TRIP FOR THE MARCH FOR
LIFE."
AND OF COURSE BILL KRISTOL, HE
NEVER MISSES AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HIT THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
SUPPORTERS, EVEN WHEN HE HAS HIS
FACTS WRONG, SAID "THE CONTRAST
BETWEEN THE QUIET STRENGTH OF
MR. PHILLIPS AND THE BEHAVIOR OF
MAGA BRATS OVER ABSORB THE
SPIRIT OF TROPISM, THE SPECTACLE
AS A LESSON WHICH ALL AMERICANS
CAN LEARN."
WHETHER A PIECE OF CLOTHING SAYS
FEEL THE BURN OR I'M WITH HER,
IT'S ALL A FORM OF POLITICAL
EXPRESSION AND THUS IT IS SPEECH
PROTECTED BY THE FIRST AMENDMEN
FIRST AMENDMENT.
YOU CAN BE OFFENDED BY IT BUT
YOU CAN'T POSSIBLY USE
INTIMIDATE AND FRIGHTEN PEOPLE
AND EVEN TERRORIZE THEM.
BUT IT IS LEFT, JOINED BY THE
RABBIT NEVER JUMPERS IS SO
DESPERATE TO BE PROVEN
RIGHT ABOUT THE PRESIDENT, THEY
SEIZE ON SYMBOLS INSTEAD OF
SOLVING PROBLEMS.
GUYS, IT'S A LOT EASIER, IS
INTENDED TO BRAND KIDS RACES FOR
WHAT THEY ARE WEARING THEN TO
DEBATE ADULTS ON THINGS LIKE
IMMIGRATION AND TRADE POLICY.
BUT FOR SOME, THE MAGA HATS,
WELL, IT SYMBOLIZES SOMETHING
VERY DIFFERENT.
>> IT WAS SOMETHING ABOUT WHEN I
PUT THIS HAT ON, IT MADE ME FEEL
LIKE SUPERMAN.
YOU MADE A SUPERMAN.
THAT'S MY FAVORITE SUPERHERO.
YOU MADE A SUPERMAN CAPE.
>> Laura: KANYE KIND OF SAW
THIS COMING.
WHEN HE SAID HE DIDN'T WANT
PEOPLE TO CONTROL HIM, TO TELL
OF WATER HOW TO THINK BECAUSE OF
THE COLOR OF HIS SKIN.
TODAY'S REAL REBELS ARE THE KIDS
WHO DARED TO SHOW UP FOR THE
MARCH FOR LIFE LAST FRIDAY.
TODAY IS REAL REBELS ARE THE
FAITHFUL WHO REFUSED TO
GENUFLECT TO WHAT'S POPULAR AND
INSTEAD DEFEND WHAT THEY THINK
IS RIGHT.
TODAY'S REAL REBELS, THEY REJECT
THE COLLECTIVIST MIND-SET OF
HOLLYWOOD, THE MEDIA, AND THE
UNIVERSITIES THAT OBLITERATE
HISTORY INSTEAD OF ACTUALLY
TEACHING IT.
AND YES, TODAY'S REBELS WILL
WHERE MAGA HATS KNOWING THAT
THEY MIGHT BE ABUSED FOR DOING
SO, LIKE THE COVINGTON KIDS
WERE.
IN THE END, IT'S REALLY NOT
ABOUT THE HAT, IS IT?
IT'S ABOUT 2020.
TRUMP-HATING FANATICS AIM TO
DEPRIVE THE PRESIDENT OF ANY
OPPORTUNITY TO BRAND HIS
REELECTION CAMPAIGN.
IN OTHER WORDS, ANTI-TRUMP
PARAPHERNALIA WILL BE VERBOTEN.
I TALKED ABOUT THIS TODAY, AND
IT'S ACTUALLY IN ITS OWN WAY A
FORM OF VOTER INTIMIDATION AND
POTENTIALLY LETHAL.
WITH CONSEQUENCES THAT ARE
INCREDIBLY DISRUPTIVE.
BY THE WAY, YOU CAN'T SCREAM
FIRE IN A CROWDED THEATER AND